hey my name's Samuel Leeds and I love
the UK I love buying houses in the UK
you know one of the things I love so
much about being a property investor and
developer in England is that this land
they're not building any more land they
can't build any more land and most of
the land that you see is Greenbelt
always protected you can't build houses
here so you bought you build a house or
you buy a house where there's an
overpopulation of people and there's a
shortage of land and there's a shortage
of houses there's only one way that
ultimately that property or that land is
going to go it's gonna go up
statistically properties in the UK
double in value every 10 years like this
is not my opinion you can you can look
back over the last hundred two hundred
one thousand years and you'll see that
property prices statistically go up over
time and here's a thing in the UK and I
think generally just across the world
we're told our whole life we're told you
know buying property is risky how can it
be risky if you're buying something
that's making you money every month and
it's gonna go up in value over time I
don't quite understand how that can be
risky but it's okay to take out a loan
to go to university to study art and
then finish University and then get
another loan to get married on a wedding
day like how is that okay but it's not
okay to borrow money to invest in
property which is an appreciating asset
it just it really just blows my mind I
mean most people doesn't if you want to
be if you want to be like most people if
you want to be average this is most
people most people work for the weekends
that's why they have the feel good
Friday because you're thinking I can't
wait till the weekend where I can on
Saturday do errands go shopping and then
on Sunday rest back to work on the
Monday again
but one day most people think they'll
retire and that's when they'll be happy
and you know what I don't think you have
to wait
retirement to live a good life I'm 28
years old and I've got a very large
property portfolio and I'll never have
to work again
and I don't say that to brag or impress
you but to impress upon you that it's
possible so let me give you a few
strategies of how it's possible number
one leverage other people's money don't
think in the terms of I'm going to work
hard on my job save up money and then
put that money in the bank or even
invest that money because that's the
slow way to do things I mean the way to
do things is to leverage other people's
money if you can if you can borrow money
from a bank or a mortgage will give you
money and they're just going to charge
you three percent interest which they
are right now you can borrow
you can borrow like a hundred thousand
pounds from a lender to put into a house
and you can pay them back three percent
three percent and they'll fix it you can
you can prepare a little bit more you
can wait ten if you can fix it over ten
years and pay four percent so if you can
borrow money and pay four percent and
fix it for ten years unless you are
completely ignorant about property you
can easily then use that money and make
15 percent 20 percent 25 percent which
means that you're using the bank's money
to invest and you're getting an infinite
return on investment so number one is
use other people's money number two this
is not like seriously important when
you're investing in property most people
you know they'll dabble a little bit
that they'll buy one house and now think
let's just see how it goes when you're
buying property the biggest risk that
you'll make and I don't say this glibly
of it I've been investing now for almost
12 years the biggest risk in property is
not buying enough because what happen is
you dabble you'll buy a house and you
think this is an asset this is great and
then 10 20 years goes by and then when
your house shoots up in value you'll be
thinking geez what what why did I not
buy more houses like I bought my first
house at 17 years old and then by the
age of 21 I was financially free by the
age of 25 I was a millionaire now I'm 28
I've got a very large property portfolio
my biggest regret hand on heart is
looking back when I started and thinking
why didn't I do more why didn't I buy
more it took me four years to become
financially free if I was to do it over
again I could do it in one week yo if I
was to do it again I could do it in one
week and again that's that glibly how do
I know I could do it in one week because
I started all over again from scratch
and I did it in one week so your biggest
regret your biggest risk is not buying
more houses and not doing more of what
you know so these guys were I don't know
if they are fans fans of me but I
thought invite them hey you got you guys
from around here are cool man so we're
doing documentary about property
investing hey you guys entrepreneurs
don't mate you don't know you don't have
to be old to make money how do you guys
see it you know how old I wasn't I
bought my first house 17
yeah mortgage yeah a man so yeah I'm
from Litchfield but I just I come down
to your neck of the woods because it's
more beautiful so yeah doing a
documentary on probably I couldn't
notice that you were in the background
so I thought maybe you could say some it
to camera give some pieces of advice
talk about what you know whatever man
you're on camera how many how many views
have we got how many views have you got
one now maybe 100,000 so you got 100,000
people watching so what's your what's
your advice stay in education as funny
because I actually teach the opposite I
teach get out of education so kids
here's my advice get out of education
because education don't the schools
don't teach you to be rich schools teach
you to get a job which sucks so get out
of education educate yourself use your
skills be smart make a lot of money help
a lot of people that's my advice
what's that I don't give money I just
teach people to make it check out my
youtube channel man you'll be in it now
awesome man take me on Instagram I'll
see you guys later
all right thanks so much see that man
take it easy number three you got to
know that the property business any
business it's not a property business
it's a people business which means that
in order to be successful in it you've
got to learn people's skills now I'm not
saying I'm an absolute expert but I know
how to communicate I know how to sell I
know how to make a deal you've got to be
able to do that in property so if you
think the property is all about numbers
and spreadsheets you're completely wrong
the most successful property investors
and entrepreneurs they know how to deal
with people
now what I'll bat this point up when
your house goes up in value you say that
property is gone up in value it actually
hasn't what's gone up in value is
someone's opinion or perception on that
property because a property is only
worth what a person is prepared to pay
for it people business tenants you know
all this property is going to give me a
thousand pound a month no won't this
property isn't going to make you
anything but the tenants that are inside
their people so when you're buying
property you've got to remember two
people business what are people want
what are people prepared to pay for you
know it's a people business learn to
speak to people it's a people game also
it's a business you know your your
product is your house your tenant is
your customer treat it as a business
treat it as a people business get the
skills don't be afraid to think
differently because most people the way
they're wired they're average and
they're wired to be poor because the
government and the banks want you to be
poor
they don't want you to be rich learn the
skills as Jim Rohn says self education
you'll make a fortune
formal education you'll make a living so
how that was helpful subscribe if you
disagree you want to argue come on my
show and argue if you're an influencer
and you disagree with me hit me up I'll
have you want a thoughtful Thursday we
can debate all day long because if you
don't debate image you're not thinking
so I'm very I'm very hopeful people on
the show and I'm gonna keep making these
videos as long as you keep watching as
long as you keep subscribing so and we
enjoy I'll see you next time
you